[Música]
buenas noches
hace aproximadamente un año una amiga
muy cercana
rocio me pidió que la acompañara a la
empresa donde ella trabaja porque quería
contarle a todos sus compañeros de la
oficina y quería contarle a sus jefes
que hasta hace apenas cinco años ella
tenía un fusil al hombro y andaba por
las selvas de colombia haciendo parte
del grupo armado
ella quería hacerlo porque en su día a
día en la oficina en los almuerzos en la
interacción con sus compañeros
constantemente era tema de conversación
los desmovilizados
y ella le tocaba hacer parte de estas
conversaciones viendo cómo se referían a
las personas que como ella en algún
momento hicieron parte de este tipo de
organizaciones armadas
recuerdo que ese día estábamos
conversando con todos sus compañeros los
compañeros no sabían de qué se trataba y
cuando ella por el fin asume el valor de
contarle su historia
con tales que fue una guerrillera
contarles porque ingreso al grupo
contarles cómo fue su vida y contarles
por qué decidió salir sin la respuesta
de sus jefes y la respuesta de sus
compañeros de oficina es exactamente la
misma respuesta que yo he venido
encontrando durante estos últimos 15
años cuando hacemos este tipo de
procesos en diferentes compañías en
diferentes comunidades en diferentes
espacios los compañeros la miraron y le
dijeron
cómo
vos eras guerrillera
no parece
qué es parecer un excombatiente
qué es parecer una exguerrillera un
exparamilitar
aquí nos parecemos
precisamente de eso es que quiero
conversar con ustedes este rato de la
urgente necesidad que tenemos como país
de dejar de relacionarlos por lo que
parecemos y empezar a relacionarnos por
lo que somos
humanizarnos
[Música]
colombianos y colombianas
y es que colombia en un poco más de 200
años que tiene como país
ha vivido un conflicto tras otro
todo el ciclo 19 estuvo plagado de
conflictos cada 7 años tuvimos una
constitución en promedio o una
modificación a la constitución que al
final del día
no eran más que acuerdos de paz cuando
arrancamos del siglo 20
firmamos uno de los acuerdos de paz más
importante porque le dábamos fin a la
guerra de los mil días una de las
guerras más crueles que hemos tenido
como sociedad y apenas unos años después
ya estábamos en la guerra bipartidista
para la década de los 60 se empezaron a
conformar los diferentes grupos armados
que hacen parte de nuestro conflicto
actual
digamos que hay un punto de inflexión a
partir de los 90 porque a finales de los
80 teníamos en el país más de 40 grupos
armados organizados y haciendo parte
siendo partícipes del conflicto
en la década de los 90 al comienzo
hicimos varios acuerdos de paz con
diferentes grupos de guerrillas
la primera década de los años 2000
hicimos acuerdos de paz con
aproximadamente 36 bloques de
paramilitares y hace un año y medio
firmamos un acuerdo de paz con las farc
y estamos en la mesa de negociación con
el ln
hay motivos para sentir esperanza hay
motivos para pensar que estamos cerca de
terminar este conflicto por lo menos
y ahí es cuando nos salió un reto
grandísimo como país
porque somos la generación que tiene que
dar ese giro somos la generación que nos
tocó asumir la responsabilidad de
ponerle fin a 200 años de guerras
y claro para poder hacerlo necesitamos
de todo el aparato del estado
necesitamos de políticas que nos ayuden
a recopilar la verdad políticas que nos
ayuden a hacer reconciliación políticas
que nos ayuden a reparar a nuestras
víctimas políticas para restituir las
tierras políticas para reintegrar a los
excombatientes
pero eso es sólo una pequeña parte
porque es que 200 años de guerras nos
han hecho un daño tremendo como sociedad
estamos profundamente fracturados
y si no devolvemos en esta historia los
colombianos nos hemos matado siempre por
diferentes razones que porque
centralistas y federalistas que porque
rojos o azules
y hace apenas un año literalmente porque
si o por qué no
ah y ahí es precisamente en esa fractura
que ha hecho que los colombianos nos
cerremos porque no aprendimos ninguna
generación anterior a nosotros de
colombianos ha vivido en paz ningún día
nosotros no aprendimos a resolver
conflictos
ante los conflictos nos dividimos y nos
encerramos entonces hoy tenemos a los
colombianos de una manera tal que se
relacionan con los que piensen y crean
igual a ellos y todo el que no
lo aniquilamos así sea simbólica o
físicamente y hablo de aniquilar lo
simbólico porque todo el que crea
diferente a mí entonces es porque es un
idiota porque no lee
porque está adoctrinado
y no somos capaces de entender que cada
persona tiene su propia historia de vida
y tienen los argumentos para hacer y
creer lo que se cree
y precisamente encerrarnos tanto no
solucionar no ser capaces de solucionar
nuestros problemas pues nos aniquila el
diálogo
y entonces no somos capaces de construir
un futuro juntos
porque en el presente no somos capaces
de conversar
tenemos varias encuestas en la que nos
preguntaron con colombianos si queríamos
y queremos vivir en paz y por supuesto
la gran mayoría digamos que sí pero
después nos preguntaban en esa misma
encuesta si estaríamos dispuestos a
vivir con un desmovilizado cerca y no si
no no
si quisiéramos tenerlo como compañero de
trabajo no no en el trabajo no
es decir todos soñamos ese futuro pero
muy pocos estamos dispuestos a hacer
concesiones para poderlo lograr y lo
pongo los desmovilizados porque es el
tema que conozco
pero nos pasa en demasiados aspectos de
la vida
estamos muy muy divididos en ese sentido
y ahí está entonces cuando como país nos
toca tomar una decisión y decir bueno
como empezamos a cómo empezamos a
derrumbar todas estas divisiones para
empezar a construir ese futuro juntos
pues obviamente entonces tenemos que
empezar a generar espacios de
reconciliación pero qué tipo de espacios
de reconciliación
no es una reconciliación nosotros no
podemos forzar el perdón porque el
perdón no se fuerza
el perdón se da
nosotros no podemos pensar que nos vamos
a reconciliar cuando todos nos
perdonemos hay que permitir que la
sanidad vayan sanando y cada cada
persona que tiene que pedir perdón y
cada persona que tiene por qué perdonar
tendrá su propio proceso tampoco podemos
pensar que la reconciliación es entonces
olvido tengo olvidemos y construyamos un
país nuevo no todo lo contrario no
podemos olvidar
tenemos que construir la verdad y
tenemos que recordar
tenemos que recortar lo más que podamos
porque no nos podemos dar el lujo de
olvidar porque recordando es que no
vamos a volver a vivir todo lo que hemos
vivido
tampoco se trata de dejar de estar
polarizados no está muy bien que estemos
polarizados y está muy bien que además
desde los extremos la gente defienda sus
ideas es que así se construyan así se
construye la democracia el problema es
que nos matemos por pensar diferente
tenemos que aprender a vivir en un país
donde tenemos extremos del pensamiento
todos los países son así el tema es cómo
nos relacionamos a partir de esas
diferencias y ahí es cuando empezamos a
construir los escenarios de
reconciliación que vale la pena que vale
la pena discutir porque hay cientos de
eventos por lo menos estoy viendo en
estos días donde la gente dice no y
vamos a hacer un escenario de
reconciliación y vamos a estar en una
mesa a un ex combatiente de las farc a
un ex combatiente de las autodefensas y
a una víctima y vamos a hacer un acto de
perdón simbólico y eso nos va a ayudar a
la reconciliación del país
por otro lado también tenemos actos
donde simplemente sentamos a tres
colombianos
a contar su historia desde diferentes
posiciones
a enseñarnos que fue de sus vidas
porque tomaron las decisiones que
tomaron y cuáles fueron las
consecuencias de esas decisiones
en este primer escenario
muchas veces por querer hacer la
conciliación tenemos terminamos
dividiendo más en el segundo escenario
las personas se conocen no desde sus
rótulos no desde sus roles
si no es de su historia de vida y es que
es muy complejo en un país que lleva 200
años en un conflicto tan otro
juzgan
cuando uno empieza a relacionarse no
desde el rótulo no desde el estereotipo
sino desde la persona a las cosas
cambian profundamente e insisto mientras
en el primer escenario muchas veces sale
la gente más dividida que como entra en
el segundo me ha tocado ver como
personas que han sufrido directamente
del conflicto se paran y abrazan
excombatientes
y les dicen hoy mi dolor ha mermado un
poco porque hoy comprendo un poco más y
me ha tocado ver como excombatientes que
hay veces no eran conscientes del dolor
que había causado porque sentían que
ellos estaban haciendo un bien se dan
cuenta el daño que hicieron y lloran de
la mano con las víctimas y deciden
empezar a hacer acciones para
transformar esa realidad
y salas es a la idea simple no
relacionarnos desde los rótulos no
relacionarnos desde lo que nos divide
empezaron a relacionarnos desde lo que
no son en sí mi amiga rocío boliver ha
pedido trabajo a su a su jefe diciéndole
que ya era desmovilizada tenía un 70 por
ciento de posibilidades de que no le
hubieran dado ese trabajo un 80 por
ciento de posibilidades de que ningún
compañero de la oficina quisiera
tenían algún tipo de relación o confiar
en ella
hoy por el contrario
ella no solo sigue trabajando allí sino
que la empresa le ha abierto la puerta y
ha contratado a cinco ex combatientes
más
en ese sentido yo creo que es muy
importante que todos hagamos un alto
a esta realidad que estamos viviendo y
no tenemos el tiempo para mirar a las
personas que tenemos al lado
pero mira a la persona que tiene en
adelante
para mirar si ustedes mismos miren sus
manos y piensen
que parecemos
y empezamos a darnos cuenta
que solamente en este escenario de las
personas que tenemos alrededor hay una
alta posibilidad de que muchos de ellos
piensen diametralmente diferente a mente
que muchos de ellos tengan una visión de
futuro de nuestra sociedad muy diferente
a la que yo tengo
quiero contarles además que dentro de
estas personas de la auditora hay muchas
personas también que hicieron parte de
algún grupo hermano
y qué vamos a hacer entonces
vamos a seguir ignorando los vamos a
seguir solamente relacionándonos con los
que piensan igual a mí porque estos que
piensan diferente o son idiotas o están
adoctrinados o no leen o vamos a empezar
a pensar cómo construir un país a partir
del diálogo
donde podamos relacionarnos con los que
piensan diferentes a nosotros
colombianos necesitan nosotros nos
necesitamos en responsabilidad de todos
empezar a dar ese paso para generar una
reconciliación porque ese país que
soñamos ese país que necesitan las
nuevas generaciones es responsabilidad
de todos nosotros construirlo
cada quien tomará la decisión
por mi parte lo más que les puedo decir
es queremos soñar diferente
derrotemos los estereotipos no juzguemos
miremos al otro como humano
y empezamos a encontrar todo eso que nos
une son miles de cosas las que nos unen
y pongamos las por encima esas pequeñas
cosas que siempre nos han dividido y que
nos siguen dividiendo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]